previously on sign of silence were we
in this car when it came down here and
this happened
your goal is to leave this place using
one of three possible ways
i'd say we just explore find things and
then assign
what direction we go afterwards damn
sean
god damn you throw something to the left
no
oh yeah bear trap going off that's
probably a bear trap
i'm going to explore denver
mark look it's us uh no look to the
right stop moving stop moving
why it seems scary oh my god look we
don't want to make noise
[Music]
walking in the camera oh what the hell
happened
i'm gonna go with jack i think jack
knows all right you me wade
hey she's coming at you guys no oh no
way not us doesn't sound like
this
no i'm dead you're dead dead he's dead
dead
well there's
oh my god oh my god horse i'm sorry
no stop
[Applause]
well oh wait all my stuff dropped so you
could probably pick it up
take the boat wait he's it's past the
horse it was that
damn horse you might not want to go near
the horse that's probably a good idea
what about mark's [ __ ]
go around the other side of the house
yeah yeah it's like a dead horse
yeah that's cool i want to see the horse
that's kind of sad actually honestly
yeah a little bit
okay i have one fuse in the cargo lift
wait
that's good i do have the other fuse i'm
about to die where mark and i are
no no no i'm coming to you yeah i'm
coming that direction though as well
oh oh wait you should definitely go
inside the house that's the move
that's long mind get the stuff wait you
can do it you see it all
that's mark stuff and it's an engine and
three gas tanks
it looks exploded over here uh stompy mc
graverson i don't know yeah
big big spider lady looked like the lady
from uh
uh resident evil 7 the mom yeah yeah the
mom
with her lovely bug collection i found
another boat engine just
hocked that into me see you later two
engines are good get us away quicker
but there's definitely can't see it i'm
not near you oh it says daniel history 7
of 13.
daniel history 1714 is that what you
wanted
perfect thank you that's pretty much the
whole note what's that horrible
noise horrible nice there's many
horrible noises that are happening in
this fight that's the horse
wait get away from this house for the
love of god going further we came from
this direction
did you get all my stuff wade i got all
your stuff
okay i'm almost to you oh okay that's a
trap i'm continuing to follow the river
yeah i'll just keep falling i'll make my
way to you
sean if you want a not stupid way out of
this place
just come to us you guys don't even know
where the boat is yet
of course we do we we just didn't want
it yet you know
yeah you're at the sawmill oh i see
a really tall cemetery or something
what's that i tried to open up a door
and something inside
yelled very loudly at me so i backed up
just from inside you just hear occupied
fine god i'll go take a dump somewhere
else
yeah all right i'm almost to wait where
did where are you in
i'm apparently taking a piss right now
all right i'm walking
in the grass but i hear the sound of
trickling water at my feet
uh-huh oh dogs a dog
oh sean's so dead right now holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh hey
hey what's up there are dogs mark
actually found dogs and totally survived
it earlier by
pure accident i screwed the dogs the
spider lady got me
real well oh we have a friend on the
bridge
yeah don't walk in the glass
crazy it's it's leaves crazy leaves
jack i feel like our team really let the
whole group down like i gotta be honest
i think god birds don't make noise well
i don't think the spider lady can dig
out of the
bridge so i think we're fine there does
this thing i would love to see you
approve that punch too
yeah i died i died to this lady oh
there's birds right on the other side oh
no
you can sprint by her yeah but there's
uh you know what actually
i'll lead the way wait
oh my god wait don't be me
don't be me wade runway we're on another
engine
hello mark mark matt mark hey a map oh
this seems like a good we're by the
radio tower
fishing village is very you did not go
toward the fishing village i see
all right follow this road
we got this all right we got no there's
a tunnel look at the map wait look at
the map look at the map look at the map
look at the map look at the map look at
look at
look at the little dotted lines that go
oh they don't go through it though
they're tunnels into it but they're not
tunnels
i think those are the caves that you
respawn in and i don't think that
there's an end
i say that's way up top wait we got a
tree on the map
wade yeah we came out of the tree up
there yeah you trust me
turn around turn it yeah i trust you
some faith but probably less than bob
all right ready three two one
back over the bridge
is he still there okay yeah just fine
i saw them cheeks it was like if i can't
clap it go ahead
yeah okay we're gonna try this mine
tactic that uh bob was suggesting
it's definitely not gonna work
you have to you have to do the song for
the whole rest until you get out of here
with the boat you can't stop
it jump over the glass i did it i'm the
best
so glad to have you on my team i'm just
staring at bob's dead body
yeah i know we could we could look at
each other's deadness
that's right no head look how twitchy no
head
break skateboard no it's just tucked up
[Applause]
this is working this is so unfair where
is this
mine uh man oh god damn it i don't know
i
got turned around oh hey
mark there is a door to the mine here
but it's sealed off we have to find a
way to open it
[Laughter]
they really don't do much if you just
keep running and don't stop apparently
that's the strategy
is not try and be sneaky or quiet in any
way
just hey that looks like a good thing to
be here that's pretty cool
real quick going forward across the
river
is swimming
[Laughter]
guys i can't explain my skills now this
is interesting
where the [ __ ] are you i have unlimited
stamina apparently oh my god
oh my god oh god you're right straight
ahead wait you gotta go
man wait do you have all the fuel you
can't die dude
i'm doing my [ __ ] best here yeah mark
i do think he really goofed around the
way and have all the good stuff
yeah that's no good let me look at the
map yeah you're finding a lot of them
hey i found the stairs
yeah there's plenty of maps here how did
i wait how did i get over here
there's a bridge there's a bridge here
oh that bridge yeah wait what didn't you
cross the line yeah i did but apparently
i don't know man look you crossed it the
wrong way somehow
it sure did oh did you just go in a
circle yep sure did all right wait are
you here yet come on we gotta go over
here
another bridge it's got a friendly yeah
well don't this bridge looks
[ __ ] fun how many bridges do we
do we're throwing them off our trail
shut up
no no no way this continues to work
apparently yes to be or not to be we
apparently are
yeah sprinting works i'm out of sprint
juice
well get it back somebody yell someone
just yell who's screaming
yeah there's a bird people i don't
believe that first yeah
run run run dude
[Laughter]
oh you're sleeping i see this person
wait
uh he's dead he's dead dead no dead
[Music]
yeah this is this feels right
jesus christ guys i'm sorry i i really
didn't expect to keep going like this
oh you can't oh it's a physical wall we
can't go that way
oh good you just have to walk around the
entire universe
oh my god drown me
kill me jesus christ drown me there you
sir please
okay do you know the way of the fishing
village hey sir excuse me pardon me
did you maybe give us a ride
he didn't what what lovely spider lady
oh hey she's coming where i saw her head
uh
oh oh oh wait but you're you're in the
water so she can't get you
is that the thing
hey how you doing we can't die even when
we try
i literally have been alive for 85
seconds in this game since we've been
playing it and mark can't get himself
killed look man look man
you know what you gotta sing the song
that's what does it you're right you're
right wait i'm just gonna go back to the
bridge where the thing was on the bridge
that thing kills you dead it doesn't
just grab you i'm just gonna
it does it does all right wait i want to
die on the bridge with you for dying
excuse me please could you murder me
please i'm ready for death
okay what's wrong with you
hit me hit me
hey you dropped something uh oh my god
how did you get thrown so high engines
are so much bigger than you you just
smiled
yeah all right jesus christ i'm so
sorry guys it's just 40 minutes
does that mean it took us 40 minutes
longer to die than bob's been alive
yes yeah yeah okay now we know what
we're doing right
yeah yeah i'm staying away from bob i'll
be
on your team bob thanks buddy you were
you were should we all be on the same
team
uh this is pvp isn't it
[Laughter]
bob just stay away from me here yeah
okay
good i know you're very you got very
weak ankles i hate for you to die within
a
foot of the car again all right i'm in
i'll wait for you bob
oh there you are i say that when we hit
the fork in the road that one to the
fishing village one to the other way we
we take that split
explosion less traveled or something and
then whoever gets the better thing
wins no one come near me i'm scared
bob i'm here there's no flashlight for
me it's in the trunk right there
oh there we go okay not everything is
set against you
jumping over the wood let's go [ __ ]
bob's gonna die
okay fine good i haven't played this
game before so i don't know where
anything is
it's new to me keep bob alive for at
least 30 more seconds
all right sounds good man if one of
those things gets near me
i'm songing my way back to safety and
apparently just jump in the river you'll
be fine
you know we said when we get to a fork
in the road i think we just lost the
road yeah where's the road
yeah why is it marketing this i don't
know i don't know
i don't know the road just did he waited
first oh
it was to the right there we go yeah
very dumb
don't worry wait let me help him okay oh
man
yeah go for it oh wow it snaps back
on wanted dibs i wanted bob to get a
chance
all right rescuer
guys i got an achievement
all right i'm doing it i'm spreading
past i'm going this is if i take
if i take one more step this will be the
farthest i've ever been from home
come on sam all right which way we want
to go
i don't know danville sawmill river coal
stone yeah there was tons of stuff i
want to go to the trusting village
i've never been down here yeah i was
going to church
i've really got a great experience in
this game so far so i get why you don't
want to
spread out and you know get your own fun
lady
there's a lady there i'm out of sprints
hang on
i'm watching so i'm helping yeah thank
you i'm not adding to the problem so
that means i'm helping
yes
that's survival instincts right there
look at those idiots not being in the
river
all right well it's probably safe over
there now yeah probably fine god damn it
do you know where he died when yeah
right next to that little shack thing oh
he's not permadead though hey i found a
new item
fuse oh nice dude yeah
ooh what's on the edge of this dock oh
hey sean looks like you're going north
flare gun i'll take that
sean i really wanted to stick together
for this run yeah i really wanted to be
a quad i feel like i said that yeah
huh that's fine guys
it's not me it's someone other than me
oh my god being alive is so fun guys
yeah
it's pretty cool drinking the only thing
i like is that i'm alive right now
yeah nothing compares such a high i'm
not even gloating because someone else
is dead
i'm just actually happy that i'm alive
uh jumping badge but
how my foot's in the trap
wait where's my heartbeat going what's
fascinating
look out for the birds oh wait just run
right up okay
okay well there's no river here to keep
me safe so i'm probably gonna die now
uh it looks like we gotta either split
up again because there's two paths here
one goes to the left to go
i'm guessing the one going down will be
the fishing village
i am not leaving mark's thighs i'll take
the path to the left then all right
sounds good man
guys i have two fuse i i found another
fuse and i have a fuel can
so we just need one fuse and then it's
home sailing
i also find a dude with no head i don't
think he's helpful did anyone else hear
a voice whisper in their ear
yep no but i don't want a house before
not today
oh this is the church oh i wanted to see
the church
dude it's probably prayer this is a
ripper of a church here
yeah straight ripper straight actually
i've always wanted a great
s banger of a church okay door does not
work
there's a lot of whispers i guess it's a
really strict church yeah there's a
prayer there's vines thrown out of the
oh there's goop it's bad it's goops so
yeah
that's more of a hey okay i'm not gonna
go there
bob you shouldn't no don't that's bad oh
he looks really upset
yeah okay well it's probably all the
whispering that won't stop
yeah i'd be mad i feel like i feel like
if i lived next to the whispers like
that i would be pretty upset about it i
wish a different door opened
hey mark is this one dead i think this
one's dead yeah i didn't make any sound
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
i'm indoors oh hey you want a flare i
found a bunch of heads on a stake
yeah i did cool oh good and my light
went out
right when i'm next to daddy long legs i
like how it's pressed e to lift
yeah well you know even lift bro it's
the importance of lifting
oh my god
i don't know man look ask him
her are we safe or jumping off the
mountain my survival issue
is telling me go but mark i wanted to be
with you forever
run away fast just keep running away
from my problems
oh my god where are you going you're so
far away
i'm done with the church
okay everything's fine jump off that's
fine oh
you got to be kidding me
you're not dead dead right i got
spider-laded it's fine all right well
this is probably my merrily way keep
going to the fishing village i'll meet
you there
oh no i don't know where that is where
is that from the church is that like
south i don't know man fishing village
is directly south of where you come out
of the tree
where the hell am i going oh [ __ ] the
fishing village wouldn't be up in this
mountain would it
yeah bob's at that tree so
bob i'm close to you yeah yeah do you
want to stay with team all the fuses and
fuel
yes well now hold on too bad i've gotta
use i said yes i'm a team player guy
i'm gonna deactivate the bearings all
right i think this don't come over here
oh son of a [ __ ] i'm so dead now
running away because it always works for
mark i'm gonna run this way in the dark
my flashlight's dead there's a bear trap
there holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i think i'm
alive
i found the third field oh
works so much of the time it works a
hundred percent of the time yeah
where do i go for the fuse uh wade has
one and i have two that's enough
which symbol on the map is that uh the
engine
that's the car you guys uh engine look
one is that the yellow one i thought
there was one more
thing i think there's one more thing for
that use the lift after installing new
fuses that's it
oh okay well that seems easy if he
doesn't get his views yeah if i die
you know where i'm at yeah sure mark and
i are practically side by side right now
you lost and didn't you oh forever ago
before bob died really oh god yeah we
were we were very apart
can you just walk back to the cargo i'm
just echo locating my way to the
irishest man in the server
i'm getting in a box guys i'm good
i made it that guy has the same strategy
guys i actually think i found a way to
be completely safe in this game i
i um i found a box other than hiding in
the water no i found a box i jumped in
the box and i feel so safe
are you guys headed towards the uh the
the thingamabob
all right cool man that's dope see there
bro
i'm trying my best to oh god do i have
to go all the way around this oh i am
now oh good i found it
nothing in it
i'm dead it didn't work
lady strategy didn't work i don't know
if you can get away from her
oh i'm at the church dude church is fun
church oh no i think i just found mount
[ __ ] myself you guys are also
not here we left the church long ago
i'm coming back to you guys oh no
remember that whole don't die thing no
oh
man that's wait how are you gonna ask a
question
okay i'm on the road i was i died on the
road right north of the church
i don't know which way to go i heard
lots of whispering in that mark
where are you i'm uh you're close to us
yeah i'm on the way should i go back and
look for a fuse
well yeah i've got we're kind of lost in
this we gotta go to the church mark
we only have two now well why didn't you
guys get three as a backup plan
i didn't find three what did you guys
find well
hold on now i technically i did i found
one on your dead body
run and sing the song
that's not the song
that's my that's my artistic
interpretation of the song yeah
not everyone's an artist i'm having a
bad time
that's great there's a lot of whispers
inside this house
oh man those crows are annoying yeah
this is what got me killed actually
there was nothing else around but the
crows went off and
lady longlegs popped out and took me
into the soil you're part of the earth
now
i'm a sweet summer child so you said you
died on the church
well that's a problem leaving the church
you can't get me oh horsey shut the [ __ ]
up
listen that you don't have to talk to
the horse like that i feel like that's
completely unnecessary
it looked at me and it's dying statement
yeah that's what
horsies say okay yeah why is this the
worst place in the whole
goddamn game more importantly why are
you still there
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me
rather not do me in the butt
respectfully decline smash or smash
can we really knock it out where are we
what are you doing i think i'm literally
back in the exact same place again i am
what have you done what have you done no
ah there's the damn crows you know they
ah
well here i go
i think i'm dead for good this time
there's my
dead body hmm you're right in front of
us
hi what what
hi hello we're all here now i don't know
where here is
wait isn't this the road back to the
lift this is like we need to go that way
though because we need to go to the barn
so i can grow or the the
church so i can grab that last fuse
[Laughter]
no no okay the trick is reminded of my
past
that it really is like if she comes out
you gotta you need a rock
or water i got a flare gun and my wits
yeah i think i might have been right
next to stuff you dropped
wade because i saw a yellow marker on my
map and i
i don't know what it was but i was two
inches from it and then i got killed
it was exactly yeah no you were
definitely this direction-ish that's
where i was trying to oh wait there's a
fellow over there
that's just the gravel right
yeah but the church is left do you know
that go to the church i don't want to
die with my two feet that's where the
fuse is
i have to go put mine in before we lose
them let me double back and get your one
yeah i think we're i'm going to follow
jack and we're going to make sure these
two fuses
all right all right you guys safely
escort the fuses i'll make my way to the
church
all right wade just be aware i think i
was close but there's a pile of crows
right on your thing
a pile okay what the hell is our car
crash
murder of crows
okay okay wait there's a sign post here
there's a sign there's something really
bad to my left
[Music]
oh dude no oh look out
i'm alive i'm alive i'm okay i'm good
this is good this is the town
area oh hey mark there's a there's a
yellow marker on my map yeah that's the
thing is that your items
the other marker on your map is a note
isn't it i don't know this is where uh
sean got grabbed
oh mm-hmm oh hey pie classic
all right wait come on here's the arm
make it snappy oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
almost back to the car
that's a good call wait those good call
thank you thank you see the lift
oh that's probably fine i'll wait for
the light to come back on before i step
on the dead man's face
you didn't even step on him all right
well you know what fine bob where are
you
i'm following you i'm coming underwater
okay we're at the cargo lift we're good
wade's your version is more benny hill
can i can i hear the right version again
i need to
i call phone a friend uh going through
the forest
[Music]
it's more there's no like necessarily
right way of doing it but someone's
doing it wrong there's an absolutely
wrong way to do it yes
yeah hey he's got the fuse guys i'm
staying
i'm staying at the place where wade
needs to come all right friends i'm on
my way back with the fuse
i'm literally standing in the lift
waiting to leave
he's got okay he's not running i don't
know why well there was a lot of bad
things here i was trying to leap back to
the road
you can outrun them if you come to my
name
i'm on the river all right in a van down
by the river
why is there bad things near me wait
that's not supposed to happen oh
why is there a trap here how far away
are you
i'm in the deep south
the deep south got it wait if you ran it
would be a lot better
[ __ ] just ran i'm i'm just ranting
look to your left look to your left oh
hey
yeah this way should i just uh shortcut
to you yeah
how are you doing good i've been where
you are i'm watching i'm watching wade
you know it's really uh interesting his
technique oh
now now wade's view got a lot better all
of a sudden
it did didn't it yeah it did wait not so
fast that's not so fast oh you take your
time
this is scary thing i have a cargo lift
to be on
yeah you know i got a lift for you to be
on
you sure you do got a lot of cargo that
needs lifting
oh wait flare go no wait it's fine okay
wait wait go i'm sprinting
wait you need to be the only one i'm the
only one that matters come to me
yeah i'm just saying i shot him
with the [ __ ] thing you didn't go on
a
every road whatever man yeah the view
really
reviewing the game is gone yeah it's i
don't really like this
wait what are you looking for just go
come on
bad things down run
let's go come on
i'm just reflecting on all of the nice
ass that's forever going to be left in
the forest yeah it's a shame it's a damn
shame
literally the lot of prepares my dude
didn't have breath again that made this
trip worth it or
rotting in a female that's it that's it
wade that's the lights that you need to
head to
yeah yeah come on wade come on
oh man remember the good times when we
crashed our car and nearly died then we
all survived just have two of us still
die yeah
good times good times all right bob i'm
here with the where's the fuse
it's in here come to me it's exactly
where i am
where's my fuse come on
there it is nice do you want to pull the
lever bob
oh can i yeah it's right there wait can
we get a thumbnail of this can you stand
uh a little further back and get like oh
you wanna
no you look at me and get like a
thumbnail
nice
oh
why did you possibly believe that i
don't know
because i'm a guy who appreciates a good
oh
my god i do appreciate a good thumbnail
you know
that would have been incredible i went
four o'clock
[ __ ] turns out this is among us
and i'm the imposter yeah fair enough
fair enough oh
noise making i might have excellent job
excellent job do you see how cautious i
was
yeah you see how yeah you were a five
and a half yeah that's why i'm
always alive because i'm the only one of
us that's ever
careful how do we know it's safe on top
of that lift
it's totally it's a totally different
world you're 150 feet higher than you
were not even related
the different planes
you